the 70s show that's a big break right
because now you're a regular i wanted a
different show what did you want so i
got a different show that day oh i got a
soap opera with a hot guy in it yes the
soap opera's no longer on the air now
this is you're about 14 years old right
when you got that seven ninth graders
you were in ninth grade they were
looking for someone who was at least 18.
did you you lied and told them or you
just kind of didn't tell them the truth
i failed a little yeah i mean it was one
of those situations where i really
didn't even want the sh this is the
truth so
it was pilot season and i wanted this
soap opera because it's so proper i had
a really hot guy in it and i was 14 and
that's really all that mattered right um
so i was like i don't really care about
this weird show about the 70s i don't
understand it but this this show is
great right
and my manager is like you're crazy and
we're going to go for the show and i was
like whatever
so um so i auditioned for 70s and the
characters supposed to be 14 but in all
television they want you to be legally
emancipated so you can work longer hours
and so i must have at one point said
something to the extent of yeah they're
like are you 18 i must have been like
yeah sure i was clear if you watch a
pilot i am clearly a child but it's
smart i mean in show business they say
if somebody if somebody asks when i
filled out the paperwork for like the
what would like the producer call like
towards the very end i was like oh by
the way i need a studio teacher and they
were like would come again if somebody
if somebody says to you they say show
business can you ski you just say yes i
can ski and then you go figure it out i
didn't know how to swim until something
and i did a movie called piranha and
they were like can you summon us like
totally i can swim with piranha
piranha don't eat me yeah but but but
you know when you think back on your
life
did you get the soap opera and turn it
down or did you just oh you did because
your manager said
you're
thank god you took it because that 70's
show became a big hit how many years
were you on that eight years eight years
70's show changed my life forever yeah
now i think it is unbelievable to me
that ashton kutcher was on that 70s show
he was your first real kiss not a kiss
on the cheek on that show
and and yet it wasn't a romantic
relationship ever right there there was
no romance there no because remember i'm
14 he's 19. i mean there's something
very no that's weird you kissed him when
he was there was that be clear he had to
kiss me i don't know who it's weirder
for the 19 year old kids and the 14 year
old the four-year-old like
my nerves oh my god do i remember this
and bonnie turner who created our show
was
so wonderful because i was so nervous
about the entire experience and she was
very well aware as i think the entire
crew was
she bought me perfume and lotion
and brushing your teeth like she was
like this always made me feel pretty and
i was like great idea and i like doused
myself with all of this it's like you
were a vampire bride having to go you
know yeah but
ashton ashton being the good looking uh
suave guy that he is
uh that uh i would think that for you it
would be like oh my god you must have
had a little crush on him here's the
crazy part and i say this and nobody
believes me i believe you thank you
howard yes i never looked at him as
somebody that was good looking
i never looked at him with somebody that
wasn't i just was like here's like a guy
that i'm working with for eight years
and he's really smart and i had to do
chemistry and he was better chemistry
than i was so he helped me with my
chemistry homework and when i was
grounded he would drive me home like he
was do you think he was attracted to you
no oh my god no
listen you know him a little bit i can
promise you he was not
to a 14 year old child so when you get a
script when you get a script and it says
you are going to kiss ashton kutcher
so so all of a sudden that sets
something off on you because you're
saying hey i'm 14 years old i'm feeling
insecure all that kind of stuff and you
wanted to to i don't know i guess you're
just nervous about kissing him do you go
and rehearse in his trailer kissing him
or uh
that's like people's fantasy
no but i don't mean that in a creepy way
i would think maybe that would take some
of the um discomfort you rehearsed like
four days out of the week right to a
second but you don't
actually kiss until the last day i see
and so do so so this thing occurs and
again it was very sort of mechanical it
did there was no for eight years we
played boyfriend and girlfriend and for
eight years whether i like we wouldn't
our couple was like on and off whatever
whenever we were on um when i tell you
there was no romance between those two
human beings when you went through
puberty on that show which you did which
i did the first year right and yeah
and you describe you grew like five
inches and you know i mean i like to
think so everyone still thinks i'm um a
little petite but i'm like i totally
grew you guys my boobs went from like
eight to eight plus so like that's gross
you